how many days has it been since
September 23rd 2017 how many days ago
was September 23rd 2017 it was 13 days
ago 13 days okay that's a more accurate
number so technically it's now been
almost two weeks since I got my iPhone
eight it's funny cuz in the comments you
guys always say I bet you Steen's gonna
make a two days with iPhone video or a
three day with iPhone video 15 minutes
with iPhone video or whatever new
product it happens to be you could
substitute the iPhone 4 or whatever that
product is now I didn't do a one-week
with iPhone 8 because I posted pretty
much eight days straight of iPhone
videos I think a lot of you guys have
been looking for an updated video on
what do I think how am i liking it am I
having any issues so here we are we are
two weeks in with the iPhone 8 and I'm
not gonna lie I absolutely love this
phone while there isn't a noticeable
difference just by holding it just by
looking at it from either side I mean if
you are a very perceptive person and you
can tell that this is a gold phone then
yes you're gonna be able to tell of
course I have a case on it if I didn't
have a case on it this is what it looks
like just in case you haven't seen it
yet if you haven't seen it yet does that
mean that I haven't been making enough
iPhone videos now the number one thing
that I like is this phone is much much
faster especially running iOS 11 now I'm
not the only one that is been
experiencing a lot of issues with iOS 11
my phone has been crashing a lot you
guys have told me this I've been getting
tweets a lot of my friends have been
having issues and really when it comes
down to it I don't feel like iOS 11 was
a hundred percent ready to be released
to the public it still feels like it's
in beta but there are still some issues
that I feel like they're working out so
hopefully those all get resolved very
very quickly because it definitely is
annoying what I'm doing something
especially doing screen recording
there's been a few times where I've been
halfway through filming a video and I
have it all synched up so I'm talking to
my camera I'm screen recording my screen
and then
my phone just restarts and that means
that the screen capture that I was
recording also stopped recording and did
not save I have been using I was 11
since beta 5 which has been a pretty
long time at this point so I've
definitely seen iOS 11 at its worst but
going back to how fast this phone is
being able to take photos being able to
switch through all the portrait lighting
effects editing exporting videos it's
significantly faster than the 7 and I
would say if you're an average phone
user you might not really notice that
huge of a difference if you're coming
from the 7 to the 8th but for somebody
who does basically everything like runs
their entire life and business off of
this phone it's made a huge difference I
love all of the new video quality
options being able to shoot at 4k 60
frames a second at 240 at 1080 it's
pretty great even though my do follow
this 4k 30 that's what I usually post
most of my videos and it is so great to
be able to have that slo-mo option
you gotta get it
Wow
one thing that I do wish was a little
bit easier is it takes a while to get
into the settings to change the quality
but you have to go into the system
settings and then you have to go to the
camera settings and you have to go
through in school through and figure out
which one you want to pick I just feel
like it should be something that is
easily integrated into the camera app
like you shouldn't have to leave the
camera app to change those settings I
just don't understand why there's not
like an option that I can't just like
click and swipe or something and it'll
automatically change here I just feel
like that would be easy and logical it's
kind of crazy to think that we are weeks
away from the pre-order for the iPhone
10 and a lot of you were very confused
as to why I got an iPhone 8 and why
don't I just wait for the 10 that's a
very crazy question I'm not sure why you
would ask me that like would you expect
me to be 8 and then just wait for the 10
I can't do that I have an eye in front
of my name do you expect me to wait over
a month for a new iPhone when there's a
new iPhone that's already out that I
could have in my possession for an
entire month
especially a blush gold beautiful iPhone
8 11 and 8 features is augmented reality
and to be completely honest with you I
haven't even downloaded an augmented
reality app like I had all intentions to
I was like this is so cool I'm gonna do
this all the time and it never did now
what I'm thinking about it I feel like I
probably should at least download some
so I could play with them and test them
out that could be really fun for screen
capture that can actually be a really
cool video itself do you guys have any
augmented reality apps that you would
like for me to try out you can leave
those in the comments below and I'll
check them out I made a video the other
day talking about the new iOS 11 emojis
and I just wanted to go on record and
apologize because number one I didn't
know what this was I'm so sorry I was
like oh yeah it's awesome fitness thing
I was like one of those things that you
put down and like it helps teach Julie
push-ups
it's from the sport curling I've
obviously heard of curling before but
somehow that was not something that came
to mind when I saw that emoji the next
thing that I need to apologize for is
this
this is apparently not a porcupine it's
a hedgehog guys started tweeting me
pictures of Sonic the Hedgehog and I was
just like this like I was actually the
facepalm emoji
so I guess to sum up all of my thoughts
on the iPhone 8 I really really like it
and I'm so excited that a lot of you
guys have also been loving it so I had a
few friends who decided to get the 8
instead of the 10 and that's mostly
because they really still want the touch
ID a lot of them don't believe that the
face recognition is actually going to
work the way that it's supposed to now
while it was at the Apple event I saw a
bunch of people using it all of the
phones on the floor were tied to the
person that had it and I was constantly
accidentally locking my phone so then
they had to unlock it and it was very
seamless so if you want to imagine what
that looks like basically you just look
at your phone and swipe up this is my
control center but it's that fast you
look at it and swipe up and you're in
your phone I'm feeling pretty confident
that it's all gonna work out and
everything is going to be seamless
although I did have that confidence for
the Apple watch and I just finally got
it to work on LTE granted the issue that
I was having was a carrier issue and it
wasn't necessarily an Apple issue
so other than tons of portrait photos
and slow-mo videos basically just
shooting videos about the iPhone for the
past two weeks that's really pretty much
all I've done another thing that I've
done is of course listen to audiobooks
which brings me to this month because
let me tell you what I get to share with
you what I'm listening to what I just
downloaded this let's see if you can
recognize this book it's Joey's no book
do you guys don't know Joey his channel
is Joey Graceffa and this is his third
book and it just came out this week and
I'm so excited because I just downloaded
it on audible and he's currently on tour
so if you are enjoy yourself a fan or if
you're now a new fan you can check out
his book on audible you can use my link
audible calm I just seen you can get 30
day free trial and a free book so you
guys know that I'm a huge audible fan
and I feel like for me I Drive around LA
a lot and I am
it's at least stuck in traffic so
instead of fitting in traffic it just
listening at the top 100 songs like
always audiobooks for me make me feel
like I'm actually accomplishing
something while I'm stuck in traffic
I always appreciate when you guys send
me recommendations these outside of the
things that I choose to listen to which
is mostly my friends books I get most of
my recommendations from you guys audible
is also celebrating their 20th
anniversary which is kind of crazy
because I remember what audible first
came out I mean 20 years ago I was three
so happy 20th anniversary audible and
thank you so much for supporting the
YouTube community we love you and I love
you thank you for passing time with me
in traffic so to celebrate their 20th
anniversary they are turning the
microphone over to you guys
check out audible.com slash audible 20
they are giving away 20 Volvo's to you
guys and all you have to do is tell
audible why you love them so I wish you
guys the best of luck and that would be
absolutely incredible if one of you guys
won from signing up you would definitely
have to drive it to California pick me
up take me out to pizza take me to get
some coffee and then we'll probably go I
don't know shopping cuz why not
anyway don't forget to check out all the
comm slash I've seen for a 30 day free
trial and Agua calm slash audible 20 to
enter their 20th anniversary contest and
if you guys do decide to get Joey's book
make sure you take a screenshot and
tweet it to me I'm so excited to listen
to this I'm gonna be heading out on a
trip here very shortly let's see this is
only nine hours in five minutes that's
nothing that is like a Netflix series
like I can probably finish this in two
days of traffic which is so sad to think
about so I guess going back to the
iPhone eights I absolutely love the look
of it I've told you some of my favorite
highlights of it and I am just looking
more and more forward to the iPhone 10
how many of you are still calling the
iPhone 10 the iPhone X biggadike
consciously have to catch myself every
single time before I say it I give
myself a slight pause iPhone 10
I'm probably gonna miss this home button
I am looking forward to the portrait
mode front facing camera oh I didn't
even make a video about the pixel - that
looks pretty awesome it's gonna be
interesting to see how the pixel two
handles portrait mode I've seen from
some of the demos that people have been
posting but they look really really good
unlike other phones like the iPhone and
the note 8 they all have dual cameras
the pixel still only has one they said
that they use machine learning to
determine what should be in focus
so I'm really looking forward to seeing
how that stands up to the note and the
new iPhone anyway I will see you guys in
my next video I hope you guys enjoyed
this quick little update on my thoughts
about the iPhone 8 and I will see you in
the next one have a good weekend echo
give it to you we're gonna give it to us
over to you
[Music]